So we're getting started.
Um, the sound of fury,
and this is, um, just want to show
you, um, the field images, um,
of, um, Faulkner's Oxford,
Oxford, Mississippi. Um,
so this is Rowan Oak,
Faulkner's house.
And um, this is actually the old, um,
Faulkner family house.
And you notice that I'm actually quite
a few American authors changed the
spelling of the names. So hot on, um,
used to be a t. H. O. R. N. E. So, um,
the w is an added on and likewise,
and it used to be spelled
f a L K and you are out.
So I was just an interesting fact, but
this is a trek dial, a partner house, um,
and 1904 and the little boy on a pony,
that's as they thought in there,
right there. Um, so, um,
this is, um, his stature, um,
in the courthouse square in Oxford.
Um,
and keep that this square in mind,
uh,
because in fact it will come back at
the very end, the sound, the fury,
the confederate monument in that
squares. Very important, uh,
to apply of design if already. So
just to landmark, you know, I mean,
it is the most important place in central,
square and arts with,
so it was very important and
falling and sitting right there. Um,
and this is an image of him
at work and you see that he's,
he was a very bookish author, um,
you know, surrounded by books as he,
um, as, as, as he wrote. Um,
and so we have to keep in mind that
authors are also leaders as well and what
they read, um, make a
difference to how they write.
So both, um, the creator
of his own writings,
but also read other people's writings.
Um,
and this is the mythic a unit to have you
and then tell powerful accounting your
net top county. I can always
have trouble saying this, um,
and is mad by Faulkner
himself. Uh, and it's, um,
obviously completely made up, but
very much based on, uh, uh, uh,
Oxford. And this is, uh,
Jefferson Mississippi in
Faulkner's works. So, um,
it's, it's just a really interesting
fact of Faulkner's writings,
um, that he should create
not just in the theology,
but also a whole landscape
that goes with that. Um,
and talking about
Faulkner as, um, a reader,
not just an author, but
also, um, sound of the fury.
The phrase is taken from the
Beth at five scene five. Um,
and it turns out that there's
another phrase that's awesome,
very important to him as well.
So tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow
creeps in this petty pace from day to day
to the last syllable of recorded time.
And all our yesterdays have lighted force.
The way to dusty that out out brief
candle lives for the walking shadow,
the poor player that struts and Fred's
his hour upon the stage and then is heard
no more.
Is it how told by an idiot for
Sam and fury signifying nothing.
So the title of the novel,
um,
is taken from the phrase sound and fury,
but today's Benji section is
obviously a tale told by an idiot.
And that's really the
challenge that Faulkner, um,
takes upon himself is to use mental
retardation as a constrain on duration.
Um, and to take up the challenge
that comes from that constraint.
So, um, and here, um,
I want to read you two
accounts of partners, um,
on description of how the
sound and the fury began. Um,
and one is much less
precise than the other.
And I'll say a little bit about your
upcoming paper in that context. But first,
let's look at the two accounts the
thought may himself offers, um,
that began as a short story.
It was a story without plot.
Some children being sent away from the
house during the grandmother's funeral,
they were too young to be
told what was going on.
And these are things only incidentally
to the childish games they were playing.
So, you know, this is a
fine, um, description is,
is an okay summary of the sound.
The fury is about children at the
beginning of the [inaudible], um,
being sent away from the house,
but there's kind of strange
central reality given to
her grandmother's funeral.
Um, and not being able to figure
out what was going on. Um,
that is not,
not in there.
It is very much in there
in his arm if period. Um,
but our experience with reading Benji's
exception isn't really revolving around
that particular event so far other
than obviously has moved away from that
initial account way.
So let's look at his second account,
much more precise,
much closer to what we actually
see in the Benji's action.
And then the idea struck me to see how
much more I could have gotten out of the
idea of the blind self
centeredness of innocence,
typify by children.
If one of those children
have been truly innocent.
That is an idiot.
So it was born and then I
became interested in the
relationship of the idiot to
the world he was in,
but would never be able to cope with.
And just where could
he get the tenderness,
the hell to show him in his innocence,
I mean innocence in the sense that
God has stricken him blind at birth.
That is mindless at both.
So I'll come back to this
particular very precise, very,
very good summary. Um,
of the Benji's section,
but I just want to stop for a moment
and talk about one strategy to keep in
mind,
um,
as you write your papers because
this is a writing wr class.
Um, so, um, I want to um,
emphasize how important it is to know
exactly what you're trying to do in the
paper.
That is the most important thing.
Knowing what you want to say is important.
It's just about the most important thing
as important as having something to say.
So that's why,
um,
the two assignments that accompany the
first paper at one is the outline in
which you name you itemize,
you enumerate all the things
that you plan to do in the paper.
That's very important.
Um, and the other is, um,
kind of more unusual requirement,
um, is the cover page. Um,
they're the company as your first paper
that will both describe what you're
trying to do,
um,
the parlance that you've run into in
the course of writing the paper and what
you would do differently
if you have more time.
So it was recognizing the fact that you
guys have constraints on you as well.
Time goods, right? You just
have to turn the paper in.
But if you had more time, what else would
you do? What would you do differently?
This is to color a self consciousness
about the paper as the paperwork goes into
the paper,
what you are free and able to put in
the paper at one moment and what future
projects with future versions of
the paper you might want to do.
Um,
as well as the recognition of what you
are trying to do that you haven't quite
succeeded in doing.
Okay.
So that is as important
as well is realizing that
you're trying to do something
but you hadn't quite done it.
But knowing that that's really
what you should try to achieve. Um,
so that self awareness after slight gap
between what you set out to do and what
you've actually achieved,
the self awareness of that gap is crucial
to you on your way to becoming the
writer that you want to be. So, you
know, recognizing rating as the process.
Um, you can get them maybe, you know,
three of those are the way still another,
um, third of it. Maybe more
than that, maybe, you know,
three quarters of the way. Um,
but you know, you're not
completely there. Um,
but what else do you need to do in
order in your own estimation to get to
exactly where you are?
So this is, um, you know,
I would just encourage you to give a
lot of thought to those two additional
requirements, the first
writing assignment. But now
let's come back to Faulkner.
Um,
and his account of this very good,
very precise account of
the sound of the fury.
And we know there's a number of things.
First of all,
the he is defining it is there
in a very peculiar way, right?
He's defining idiocy as the blind
self centeredness of innocence.
He's not using the word mentor,
retired patient that's very,
very important to keep in mind is
not necessarily a simple deficiency.
Um, it is blind. So, you
know, it has that aspect.
It is self centered and we'll
think about what that means,
uh, for it is to be a form
of self centered in this.
But also more than anything else,
it is a kind of innocence,
which is a good word for most of us.
So what does it mean for it? Is
there to be kind of innocence? Well,
think about that.
And in fact,
the argument that I would like to
make is that not only is Benji himself
innocent innocence is also
what he demands from the world.
Innocence is the impossible demands that
he puts upon the person that he loves
the most catty.
And it is that impossible demands that
catty is not able to fulfill and they add
[inaudible] does about that.
So both is this about
being able to supply that requisite,
that demand,
that innocence that is coming from,
from Benji,
the demands made upon her, um, not
being able to fulfill it fondly.
And Faulkner, Ashley
stepping in, um, to, um,
supply that lack, um, by his
narrative experimentation.
So, um, it's, this is the,
what I'll try to show in the
course of this lecture, but, um,
I want to contextualize Faulkner, um, uh,
against the number of thinkers who also
thought about mental retardation or you
know, the various, uh, ways
of designated that condition.
And the most, one of the most important
is the philosopher John Locke. Um,
and this is what he says. I'm
new, very, very influential.
He was one of the most influential text
written in that end of the 17th century
incentive, very afraid, influential in the
18th century, the 19th century as well.
Um,
John Locke here in seems to the difference
between idiots and madmen that madmen
put wrong ideas together
and listen from them,
but idiots make very few or no
propositions and reason scares at all.
Okay. So we almost recognize something
else in what John Locke is describing.
Madmen put wrong ideas together and reason
from them actually he's describing a
lot of the characters and Edgar Allan Poe,
right? So it's sort of recognize that,
um, but areas, and this is really
a very good description of what,
five minutes trying to create it is put
very few or no propositions and reason
scares at all. So not being able
to put two and two together,
not being able to go from point a
to point B, that has been just part.
And so point a on beer, always going
to be completely separate, discrete,
unconnected dots is not able to
connect all the dots the world.
Um, so, so it really goes back to
John Locke in some sentence. Um,
and um, in the 19th century, um,
the institution,
how the what was called a lunatic asylum,
it's not car by that designation. Now a
mental institution is the word we use.
Uh, but when it first started
in the mid 19th century, um,
harder lunatic asylum,
and this is the one in Jackson,
Mississippi and Jackson.
Mississippi is a very resonant
and loaded word in Faulkner.
Sending someone to Jackson just
means sending to the lunatic asylum.
And it comes up in the sound of your head.
That comes up in as I lay dying.
So this is the large scale, um, housing,
concentration of the mentally
retarded in just one place.
And, um, as we move on to
the early 20th century,
um,
we're beginning to get the newer kind
of taxonomy sciences proceed by way of
taxonomy.
So we could get this 1910 [inaudible]
from the American Association on mental
deficiency. So we're sort of moving
closer and closer to our own time.
It's mental deficiency.
So the two,
three ways to categorize or
classify mental deficiency,
um, the most severe form is
the word idiot. So, you know,
actually the Falklands taking his word
from that classification is development,
arrested, age to embersol. You know,
first it's just of
course, really, you know,
that we throw it over people is actually
has a clinical definition arrested
between two and seven.
Um, and moron, again,
whether we use without thinking about it,
uh,
has a clinical definition
arrested between seven and 12.
Um, so, um,
as you can see by the
early 20th century in,
um,
the scientific thinking about mental
retardation was moving more and more
towards a bonded Tatum approach.
Right? You know, so, um,
we see the numbers right there,
age to age as to the seven
and ages to seven and 12.
Um, to quantify what's
developmental stage, um,
the, it was arrested, your mental
capacities were arrested. Um,
and how that would correlate with
various degrees of mental retardation.
Um, the person who was instrumental
was probably the most important figure.
Um, and turning a kind of
a quantitative approach,
um, into standard practice,
uh, was Henry Garde art.
Um, and um, and his quantitative approach,
um, took a number of forms. He was
physical, he was very important, um,
as to director of research at the violence
in your school for feebleminded girls
and boys. One of the first and one of
the most important, uh, for 12 years,
um, 1906 to 1918 and then he
even more important than that,
he was actually a pioneer in
Iq testing. So the 1908, uh,
translation up in these
intelligence testing, uh,
it was invented by a French
psychologist, been there, um,
and God are translated from the French,
uh,
and was instrumental in getting
it to be widely adopted.
So you know,
what we know as Iq has really dated
from that time was getting completely
quantitative numerical measurements.
Um, and then the 1912, he wrote a book,
um, kind cat family and inheritance
of feeblemindedness. Um,
so this is God as contribution to um,
and widely use.
Um, understanding of
mental retardation, um,
fall can be seen in many
ways as rejoinder. Um,
and uh,
maybe a descent departure from
this quantitative approach.
Here's it's very much a non
quantitative approach. Um,
the quantitative approach not only
anthracite is numerical measurement,
but it's very much an objective look
at mental retardation from the outside,
right? You know, it is people
who are not retarded, uh,
looking at people who are retarded
and seeing where they're deficient.
So the deficiency indexed,
the numerical index is a measurement
of how deficient they are as defined by
people who are not retarded.
Um,
farmers tell to my period is fairly
much the tell from inside the mind of an
idiot.
It is not the total by someone from
the outside looking at Benji from the
outside.
It is tow from inside the consciousness
of an idiot with the blind self
centeredness of innocence
being front and center.
That is the defining,
um,
grime of Benji's world.
Um,
so what we get is the suits,
the very recognizable modernist technique,
stream of consciousness.
Um,
and in this case of allowing for
extreme subjectivity. So, you know,
as opposed to the objectivity
of the quantitative approach,
this is extreme subjectivity.
Um,
and we see a number of features
associated with this extreme subjectivity.
One is we've seen this before,
refresh my memory about this. Um,
is that the past and the present
adjust to post, right? So,
and we can call it by different names.
That is non linear chronology.
Um,
we've also seen the private part,
primacy of smell and we'll see how that
really is the basis on which department
tells to central story
in the Benji [inaudible].
And another interesting feature
is the incomplete syntax.
I'll talk about all this.
Um, but first, just, um,
this is a passage that we looked at
before and just want to bring it back.
This is very early in the band section.
Um,
just opposing, uh, two moments, um,
that might not seem
connected to the rest of us,
but they are connected in Benji's
mine does you come to meet Katie?
She said rubbing my hands while is it
whether you're trying to tell Katty Kay,
smell my trees and like when
she says we were asleep,
whether you're moaning about Lester
said you can watch them again.
When we get to the brand here,
here's you the with so you know,
fairy content into they've um,
yoking together of two
experiential moments for Benji.
You can together one episode having to
do with his sister Cathy young logo and
the other having to deal with
luster, a young black surgeon. Um,
so those two are connected.
Benji makes no racial distinctions that
are important to register this flat,
no racial distinction. And then
Jews life. That might be one way.
Why either it might not be completely
deficient in Faulkner's estimation.
Um, but in any case, he's
not making the usual,
you know,
distinction,
but he is making instead of the connection
through the sense of smell rates are
catty smelt latreese. Um, lastly,
it doesn't exactly smelt like trees,
but he's coming up with a good
enough substitute, the Jimson weed.
So this is thoughtless
way of substitution.
The logic of substitution is
a play now in Faulkner, um,
and last days almost good enough and
it's the sense of smell the connects,
those two moments and Benji's Jay's mind.
So here I want to, um, bring up another,
um, psychiatrist, psychologist, um,
that you would recognize right away.
Um,
and that in some sense father
and is also, um, departing from,
and this is Sigmund Freud. Um, and um,
in his classic, um, on
civilization and its discontent,
Freud argues that the
development of human sexuality,
um,
makes it less and less dependent on
the census now that the sense of smell
becomes, um, less and less central to, um,
the demonstration and the
articulation of human sexuality.
So this is what throws as the development
of human sexuality seems most likely
to be connected with.
The dual inhibition of the
olfactory stimuli by me is a wish.
The Mastro process producers.
And in fact,
on the male psyche,
the row was taken over by
the visual excitations,
which in contrast to the
incident mitten or factories,
stimuli, we're able to have a
permanent effect. So this is,
we assume, recognize
the truth of what, um,
of what fry the saying that we don't get,
usually we're not attracted to people
because of the way that you smell.
Usually the first thing that gets us
is the way they look. So, you know,
he's described,
I'm not overly generalizing,
but I think that that's
probably true of lots of people.
It's the first thing that
they see is how some,
the first fact that they registered
that anyway is how that person looks,
not the way they smell. So
I mean Friday's not, um,
not, you know, this is
not untrue, but, um,
the way that he denigrates the importance
of the sense of smell is something
that one might take issue with.
Um,
and it turns out that fog nerve actually
is taking issue with that denigration
of the senses smell.
Um,
the sound of fury is obviously about
hearing that announced in the title of the
novel. But the sense of smell
is actually very important.
So what I like to do today is to
use the sense of smell as the,
in that as the connecting thread
through wish far from the towels,
the dramatic story and a dramatic stories,
obviously caddies story told through
the eyes of her brother who loves him,
loves her,
but who is completely blind and completely
self center in his love for caddy.
So the story goes on there
like this. Um, the innocence,
sexual innocence of Cali
is threatened by this.
We store precariously risk toward
twice and then it is Trenton yet again.
And there's no restoration. This
time it is lost. It's gone forever.
And that lost does something to Benji.
And we stayed in a way that is syntax
becomes incomplete and then the something
else that it's lost to Benji as well.
But
father,
knowing that innocence has to be
sheltered through acts of tenderness,
is able through his narrative to supply
that af of tenderness that is not coming
anymore from Catholic.
So it's very complicated
story is actually completely,
uh, it makes complete sense actually
to me. Um, so in that sense, you know,
it, it's for them staying
extremely coherent story,
too complicated, um, non linear
chronology of NGS section.
Um,
but it is a story that
we have to reconstruct by
following one particular phrase
that has to do with the census now.
So let's go to the first step of innocence
becoming dangerously in Japanese,
but being restore in the
nick of time. Okay. So, um,
and caddy put her arms around me and a
Shining Vale and I couldn't smell the
trees and ignore and I began to cry.
Benjamin,
Kathy said Benjy she put her arms around
me again and I went away. What is it?
Benji just said,
isn't this hat?
She told her hat off and came
again and I went away. Benji,
she that, what is it Benji?
Well, this can be done.
I went to the bathroom door,
I could hear water.
I listened to the water,
I couldn't hear the water
and Kelly opened the door.
[inaudible] she said she looked at me and
I went and she put her arms around me.
Did you find Hattie again?
She said she think how they have run away.
Hey, smell like trees. Okay.
So that is the phrase that is going to
be our guide in the reconstruction of the
drama that Faulkner is giving us.
Um,
and we know this right away that Kelly
is the supplier of tenderness for a good
pot of Benji's section.
Hookers.
Ristick gesture is putting her arms around
Benji and we can think of it both in
terms of the physical act of
putting her arms around Benji,
but also wrapping her mind around Benji.
Um,
someone who's not able to
tell her what is wrong. Right?
So Kathy tried to figure out what it
is that is making Benji cry and wish I
remember the all this
time when Benji is crying,
it's actually making this incredible
noise is this battling that's just filling
up the whole house unbearable.
Um, so you know, just like, um,
the noise and Hemingway's Indian camp,
this is unbearable noise coming
from Benji. So, you know,
just to stop that noise.
Um,
Kelly is to figure out what it is that
is upsetting Benji to this extent.
And she tries out a number
of explanations. Right.
So is it this hat that I'm wearing that
you don't mind? This making use of upset?
Wrong answer.
Can I figure out figures,
figures out the answer.
And it has to do with something that
requires go into the bathroom and turning
on the Faucet.
So this is the only thing that Benji
is going to tell us is that Kelly has
figured out what it is.
She goes to the bathroom,
he hears the water running while the runs
for awhile can hear the water anymore.
Kenny comes out,
everything is okay again.
Kennedy puts her arm around
Benji Kelly's mouth, like trees,
everything is okay and
lessons has been restored.
So what is it that was
really upsetting Benji.
We found out very soon. Next page after
they've talked me. It actually isn't it?
So, um, you know, impossible
to read. I mean, you know,
this is fairly close.
Cluing in what exactly?
Uh, was upsetting to Benji.
They'll say, Kathy said Benji
has gone to prison for you.
She stooped down and put
the bottle in my hand,
holding out to go.
They'll now,
Kelly held my hand and
their see took the bottle.
Well I declare due season
if my baby and give,
they'll see a bottle of perfume.
Just look here at Roscoe's caddies.
Smells like trees.
We don't like earthy ourselves.
Said she smelled like cheese.
So that is what was upsetting.
And J is the use of perfume that sign
that Hattie is on her way to losing
homosexual innocence.
Um,
and what is really interesting is that
on this occasion a is able to do exactly
what is needed.
Much gives away the perfume
and she uses the Pronoun we,
we don't like perfume anymore.
This fusing of herself and Ben j even
though really is Benji who objects to the
perfume,
uh,
after putting her on both physically and
metaphorically around Ben j Kelly uses
the more encompassing pronoun we,
that is the syntactic equivalent to the
physical act of putting her arm around
Benji.
So this is one moment when
we can see this clear danger.
The danger has been averted.
Innocence has been restored.
Let's look at one other moment
when that happens again.
Um,
it was two now and then one in the swing
headache came fast way in the darkness.
Benji, she said, how did you
slip up? Where's version?
She put her arms around me and I hush
and held to her dress and try to away
caddy and I ran,
we ran up the kitchen steps onto the
porridge and caddied now done in the dark
and held me.
I could hear her and feel her chest.
I won't, I won't anymore
ever. Benji Benji.
Then she was crying and I cried
and we held each other hush.
Just hush.
I won't anymore.
So I hush and Kenny got up and we went
into the kitchen and turn the light on
and catty took the kitchen so and wash
your love at the same hot Tevye smelled
like trees. Once again,
that's very reliable.
Thread that five minutes giving us.
So we've just looked at one kind of re
of arithmetic and the earlier use of the
Pronoun we re catty and Benji being two
different people but being turned into a
single unit by that first person thorough.
We,
the two of them had become one in
that earlier moment here. This,
the repetition of that kind of logic
except that it is not Benji who's been
fused with chaotic,
it was two now and then one in the
swim calving and who bow in this way,
the two of them becoming one and it is
that site that is unbearable to Benji.
So that's why she was crying and
caddied this time doesn't have to guess.
She knows it's not clear what it is
that is upsetting. Bangy so much.
So once again,
she tries her best to make
things okay for the energy again,
she puts her arm around Benji.
Um,
and then she does what is one more time.
and it is within the capacity
to do what is needed.
So she goes to the kitchen
is not the bathroom,
but it's the same really the equivalent
functional equivalent of the bathroom,
um, turns the light on turns on
the faucet one more time, right?
This necessary ingredient.
Now those are the necessary ingredients
to the restoration of innocence.
Faster soap and water
washing out her mouth.
So she wants again,
smells like trees. So, um,
we can see that cat is doing everything
that Benji is demanding from her,
but I think that we can also see
how unreasonable Benji is. Right?
So let's not romanticize
Benji and you know,
just call him innocent.
He is innocent,
but this is an innocent,
that is not only blind
to the needs of catty.
She is going to become a woman.
She's not going to be
able to wash yourself,
clean every time with soap and water.
Um,
and Benji is simply has no recognition
of catty as a separate person who has her
own developmental path.
She's going to turn from a young girl to
a woman that's her developmental path.
And because Benji is arrested at age two,
he wants everybody or you know,
whatever age to age four,
um,
because he's arrested
in such an early age,
he wants everybody to be developmentally
arrested at that age as well.
With that degree of innocence and
bad Katie is not able to do for him.
So it is a very, um, uh,
impossible,
very self centered kind of
demand that Benji is imposing.
Um, on Kelly, and in that sense,
sowing the seed of its own destruction.
It is at the demand that cat is,
can never meet in the long run is almost
like the impossible demand that gaspy
is putting on these. Right. You know,
we're beginning to see actually a
pattern of people who love intensely,
um,
but in a very intensity of the love,
putting an impossible demand
on the love object. Um,
just no human being is capable
of meeting that demand.
Um, so not surprisingly, we see,
um,
this time caddy failing Benji and see
what's in this passage and what is not.
In this passage,
we were in a hall,
caddy was still looking at me.
A hand was against her mouth.
She stopped again against the wall looking
at me and I cried and she went on and
I came on crying as just ran
against the wall looking at me.
She opened the door to her room,
but I bought a red dress and we went into
the bathroom and she stood against the
door looking at me though,
should put her arm across her face.
And I've posted her cry.
So the Kurds rustic
gesture coming from Kelly,
putting her arms around Benji that
is not here in this passage as that,
just putting her arm across on those as
just doing this because Benji is trying
to get her to go the bathroom,
you know, to achieve that,
that previously try then,
you know,
solution that worked before on
Benji [inaudible] one more time.
This time,
best solution isn't going to work.
So we see it in the nonappearance of that
gesture coming from catty arms around
years.
She's now able to do that.
And we also see that non
appearance of that phrase,
Kelly's smell like triaged smell and
trees anymore and she never world smell
like trends again.
So this is a five way of telling the
story of loss of sexual interactions,
um,
completely through the sense of smell
and through it's very indirect way of
channeling it through of the mind
of some of us were mentally recall,
the retired or who can mean they can
vision can't really need that loss. Uh,
but who registered that lost as
a sensory loss rate, you know,
so he's not able to reason
but his senses to how him,
what actually has happened. So you know,
this is one way in which Benji
Ashley both knows and not knows me.
He knows really in the sense that
his reaction and says that he knows,
but he doesn't know in the sense that
he doesn't, can you give them reason,
can mean the condition.
Um,
so let's look at the consequences
of that lost on Kelly's,
what happens to energy within the losers.
Caddy in this way.
And the way father is telling that
story is by this technique af Benji not
finishing his sentences.
So let's look at this income
fixed impacts in the very, um,
all the way through. Um,
the, the Benji action,
but especially striking in this moment.
They came on,
I opened the gate and they start telling,
I was trying to say a
quarter trying to say,
and she screamed and I was trying to say
and trying and the right shapes began
to stop.
And I tried to get up the trolley,
get it off of my face,
but the bright shapes we're going again.
They would go on up the hill to where
it fell away. And I tried to cry,
but when I breathe in,
I couldn't breathe out again to cry.
And I try to keep from falling off the
hill and then fell off the hill and to
write whether the shapes.
So it is tow as a jumble of sensations.
How is this the only way, and you can
tell the story, but we can sort of know,
you know, roughly what is
going on. Um, someone, we,
we need more to know that someone had
left the gate open. So some school goes,
we're going by and Benji had
lost Kelly at this point.
He sees the school goes, it's always
looking for substitutes for candidate.
So he grabs one of those school
goes, um, I caught her trying to say,
and we can almost see that this is what
happens to this is the consequences of
what happens to Benji when
this not caddied there to
complete his sentences for
him. Right. Catty,
putting her arm around Benji is
her way of finishing his sentences,
saying what he cannot save
himself. She's not there, um,
to do that for him.
So Benji sentences are
left hanging incomplete,
always trying to say, uh, without the, uh,
predicate without an object,
uh,
without just as grammatical
compliments who, uh,
finishing that sentence. Um, and um,
that's just how things are going to
be for him forever. Um, you know,
trying to say something, trying to, um,
express himself to the world without the
resources of the language and without
Amanda capacity to do so.
So we also know what happens when you
know that really this is the moment.
What is Faulkner is actually
registering mental deficiency.
Something is lacking from the Eia
is missing from Benji's. Well, um,
and something is happening
to be energy as well as red.
It looks like something has been put
on his face. Um, he can breathe, um,
that he is fighting it,
but this thing is happening to him.
So what is it that's happening
to Benji at this moment? Uh,
we see the physical manifestation was
happening to him just a little later.
I got an address and I looked at
myself and I began to cry hush.
Those that said,
looking at looking for them
in going to do no good,
they are gone. Okay. So
that is what happens
to Benji. Um, you know,
I don't think it was, you know, I
think that we know what happens.
We know that people who
are mentally retarded,
who are threatened to others get
castrated. It's still happens.
Um, so, um, is, um, a very graphic,
um,
uh,
rendition of the lost that comes
to Benji when he loses caddy.
But you know,
I would say even though it was
a horrible fate and you know,
Benji can really bear
to look at it himself.
So he really has that degree
of self consciousness. Um,
but I have to say that it actually shows,
um,
some degree of narrative
tenderness on the part of the fog.
And I really want to emphasize
those because they magically,
the tendonitis got not going
to come from caddy. You know,
she's lost that ability.
So something else has to supply that
tenderness that will show it and shelter
Benji and thought that is
the one who was doing this.
So on the one hand it is terrible that
there should be that lost coming to
Benji.
But at the same time that lost once again
establishes a bond trading Benji and
having,
they do have something in common even
though had he doesn't know it and Ben j
the last person to be able to say it.
And then that condition nonetheless,
there is a bond is almost as though Kenny
has suffered this terrible thing that
she was very there, she was devastated
by it. This was a point in time where,
um, you know, to be, um, um, to,
to have that loss is a kind of
incredible stigma on, on, on, on, on,
on, on caddy, um, that when
something's rooms alive, um,
and Benji's live is also
ruined, devastated, um,
in a parallel fashion.
So the two of them as they do have it
would have been pushed this point so far
as lily, not the consultation to anyone
to have that particular thing in common.
But this is the cemetery,
um, that Faulkner is, uh,
creating, creating for Benji
and, and, and catty. Um,
we'll look at one other moment and this
is the very and of the Benji section,
um, in which we see maybe a
more compelling, more, um,
you know, um, persuasive,
uh, way in which, um, uh,
shelter could be device for Benji
without it being physically there.
So this is the very,
and of the [inaudible] section,
and I'm telling you what I want to say,
but obviously we're back
to experimentation, um,
on the part of the Faulkner.
But let's just look at his. Um,
father went to the door
and look at us again.
The dog came back and he's too black in
the door and then the door turn black
again.
Kelly tells me,
and I put here is all and the
jobless and something I could smell.
And then I could see the windows where
the trees were busing than a doc began to
go and smooth bright
shapes like it always does.
Even when caddies says
that I have been asleep.
Um,
this is coming at the very end of Veggie
section where they study three and back
again to being a young boy.
Right?
So this is what the nonlinear
finally reveal to us.
What the nonlinear chronology
is doing for Benji.
B being 33 is no place for Benji to be,
it's a terrible place.
No one wants to in his
condition at this course,
the age when Christ was crucified
and obviously that's in Redlands. Um,
so he,
Benji is going to be crucified at
age 33 and father doesn't want him,
you know, was that crucification
to happen and to be registered.
But he doesn't want that to be
the experiential ending for Benji.
So because he is telling the
story in a nonlinear fashion,
he can choose to end the
story at a much earlier point.
And he can do that because
path and presence that always
just oppose and benches
mind anyway. And he can tell the
difference between past and present.
So at the ferry and a brand new section,
he actually goes back this
a bit of time travel for,
he gets to go back to a very
satisfying moment in time.
And let's look at how this moment
reconstitutes all those things to the
[inaudible] to Benji.
Um,
the dark comes back to trees about
saying so you know, this, this um,
sight and sound fuse.
Um,
that really is the kind of the defining
feature of a band as well and have no
explanation of law but very
reassuring. Um, visual images.
Um,
father still alive are black and the
door and then the door turning black and
that's how Benji wants it to be,
wants to be asleep,
wants to be in bed with
Katee holding him and um,
he could smell something
was really interesting is that there's
almost no need to mention that Kelly
smells like cheese and there
actually is the best envision.
Even that phrase caddies smelt like
smelled like trees already suggest that is
she was in of not smelling like trees,
right?
Bend in this dimension that Kelly's melt
like trees when she started smelling
like trees when Nolan. And so even
the appearance of that phrase say,
knows that there's already a danger
present and maybe has been avoided,
but they injured,
has been there not been able to name that.
And she actually also smells a month on
home muddy draws that she's completely
Monday from fighting in
the wild with Quentin.
So his males tree is males,
mark the smell of an innocent young girl
and that is the smell that Benji ones
to die smelling. Um, so
he gets to smell that.
But what is also interesting is that
there's a kind of a bag with reference to
the previous traumatic
moment, right? The smooth,
bright shapes that we just go back
to that horrible traumatic moment.
Um,
those are the bright whirling sheds that
were forced upon Benji at this moment
when he's completely helpless,
when it's pen and died down when
Katty is nowhere to be seen.
Um,
those bright whirling shapes and
this supremely traumatic moment,
those have been reconstituted
as comforting shapes that
he just doesn't know why
they're there,
but his falling asleep and caddy is
telling him that he's falling asleep.
He doesn't even have
to work to talk about,
describe the condition of
being asleep, but as, okay,
this is really one moment where not
having language is completely okay and
Foglar has been managed to bring
Benji back to the point with life.
Ashley is bearable and in fact
satisfying. Um, he can talk on,
can't really do more.
One that can really bring true happiness,
actual objective happen is we can bring
objective happiness to Benji at 33.
The only way you can bring is subjective
satisfaction to Benji at the age 33
acting as if he was much younger
and still having Kelly there.
So, um, you know,
that the narrative experimentation
is really completely, um,
thematically consequential as well.
Um,
and that's really is the
story that fall in Italian.
So we'll move on this time and
to Quentin section session too.